eight bedroom main house and a
two-bedroom guest house for 55 million
dollars thank you
hi i'm seth rogan and i'm about to go on
a shopping spree with gq
um do i come out of this with any actual
i don't think so
let's pick a vacation luxury treehouse
on a rwandan volcano with jonah hill
does it literally come with that oh okay
this is how this is this is you
projecting how i would go on vacation
somehow this luxury rwandan tree house
did not get jonah hill to agree to be a
part of people's vacation
it's a villa on the slopes of an eroded
extinct volcanic crater accommodation
all meals local drinks government taxes
is there some rooms
pretty nice you know if i'm making a
list of places i want to go on vacation
is a rwandan volcano high on the list
not necessarily it's not something i'm
like myself like manifesting but
now that you throw it out it sounds nice
me and jonathan would do great in the
jungle together i'm taking a moment to
think have we been in a jungle together
is there a thing i can we probably been
in jungle like settings with one another
uh i would love to go to a jungle with
jonah especially on the cusp of a
rwandan volcano a luxury one day trip to
antarctica with jay baer a shell 14
grand a person private jet from cape
town you got a four by four sherzin
you're mountain biking no thank you a
picnic with thousand-year-old ice in
your cocktail that's a [ __ ] stretch
if there's a million-year-old rock in
your cocktail
i don't know if i need to go to
antarctica jay nothing personal i i
would like to go on a vacation with jay
but i i don't know if antarctica is the
thing the thing for me construction
crane turned hotel in copenhagen denmark
with paul rudd a concierge team to tell
you everything you need to know about
the crane oh thank god because i will
have a lot of crane related questions
the crane is uh 1200 bucks a night
around
which is not bad for a crane uh
i mean i do i would like to go to
copenhagen do i do i want to stay in a
crane while i'm there when i think of
like denmark and the architecture the
things available does a
abandoned construction crane is that the
is that the hoogie thing that leaps out
at me when i'm thinking of uh denmark no
it's an industrial experience i guess
you would say if you crave an industrial
vacation experience then a crane is for
you free spirit sphere in qualicum beach
canada with lauren miller my wife for
374 dollars a night you know we wanted
to stay in like an orb
for a while we got a lot of orbs pinned
it's got two windows that open it has
electric heat see the toilet might be
the problem uh electric composting
toilet outhouse at the base of the
sphere i get lauren do that for one
night maybe
she is not like an unconventional toilet
situation she prefers
a a normal infrastructural north
american toilet
and it's one of the reasons i love her
i'm going with the wife sphere
what kind of [ __ ] doesn't pick that
for zelda we're gonna shop for my dog
who is pretty picky not easy to shop for
but let's see what you guys got the taj
mahal dog house uh we start all custom
house uh custom doghouse design projects
with an in-depth consultation with the
dog i assume followed by uh drawings and
renderings it's 40 grand
which is a lot for a dog house that my
dog i'd say has a 10 chance of using
sometimes you know this would be lost on
my dog she's generally laden's on like a
sweater that's been left on the ground
next thing for zelda uh la rochelle
designer dog bed 2 515 bucks padded
headboard in case our dogs get it on
reversible black and white imprinted
fabrics this is a [ __ ] bed for dogs and
i don't my dog might be too old for this
an a24 dog leash proof you can brand
anything 46 bucks i don't know that's a
lot for what essentially it's a long
rope with a hook on the end have they
even made a dog make a dog movie before
you're getting into dog leashes a24 i
don't need a dog leash that reminds me
of the green knight the ice excel dog
caller
cubic zirconia diamonds ah already a no
took over 100 hours to create i don't
know like are you bragging about that my
dog weighs a total of like 18 pounds i
think this would not be good for her i'm
going taj mahal and if there was a 1
chance she would uh
like this i would be more than happy to
buy it for her so yeah i'll take the taj
mahal dog house
let's check out some farm properties
finally there's one thing you think of
when you think of me it's that i
probably want to buy a farm property
the aspen mary go ranch eight bedroom
main house and a two-bedroom gas house
for 55 million dollars
first [ __ ] you that's insane oh and a
two bedroom guest house
five garage bays an eight stall barn and
a 13 000 square foot gym whoever built
this house is an [ __ ] that's like if
like the guy from american psycho like
lived in aspen
this is what he would build portuguese
nature preserve 5 400 square feet now 15
acres big 40 000 square meter park 11
million includes a residential house and
a pavilion to accommodate events for up
to 300 people this sounds lovely have i
stepped foot in portugal ever in my life
and did i ever plan to no
but that does not rule this out hi in
the running portugal farm on a
biodiversity site in chinese 8 million
uh 400 grand approximately 100 hectares
don't know what that is this place is
nice not my style architecturally i
would say ooh do not like the inside at
all
riverfront farm in bella coola canada
1.5 mil four bed two bath as opposed to
eight bedrooms for 55 million dollars i
like how they just say canada it doesn't
say what province it is i mean if you're
going on a farm what kind of what kind
of crops
you'd think i'd say weed but i wouldn't
grow weed because i know enough about
growing weed to know that you need like
a lifetime of knowledge to even begin to
grow the type of weed i would be
interested in smoking
so i wouldn't bother growing weed i like
animals i rescue animals on my farm i'd
have dogs each one with their own taj
mahal i'm going portuguese i like this
place it looks cool you know it'll give
me a reason to go to portugal
let's shop for some vintage teas
i like vintage i own some vintage
t-shirts some just i haven't thrown away
since 1993
and due to my own inaction they've
become vintage t-shirts wu-tang clan
cream graphic t-shirt four grand that
seems like a lot well i don't i can't
fathom why that wu-tang clan t-shirt is
four thousand dollars i mean it's just a
move like
is this
i don't get it it's made with like old
dirty bastards blood or some [ __ ] like
that pink floyd the wall jumbo print 500
bucks pretty cool shirt pretty cool
shirt kirk cobain graphic print tree
just straight up kirk cobain shirt it's
not a nirvana shirt it's just a kerkobe
shirt
ooh wow with his journal this is not
official i can't imagine kurt cobain
uh condoned that but maybe he did a 1992
mile davis t-shirt the height of mile
davis's uh popularity uh 250 bucks i
generally personally gravitate toward
these band t-shirts that
like have some sort of imagery that i'm
familiar with it was like tied to the
album released or something like that or
tied to a certain song like that thing
does this wu-tang cream t-shirt even say
cream anywhere on it like i have a
wooten cream t-shirt and on the back it
says cash rules everything around me
i did not pay four thousand dollars for
it i'll tell you that
but because this isn't real money and i
like wu tang i'll go with the four
thousand dollars wu-tang cream t-shirt
it's the one i'm most likely to wear if
i'm being honest
pottery tools let's shop for some
pottery tools i got a lot of pottery
tools i got in the pottery because my
wife had done pottery lauren she knew i
liked uh hobbies she always uh implored
me to take a pottery lesson and uh
finally we did and i really uh and i
really loved it uh sculpey clay from
michaels 29.99 what is this like fimo i
guess kind of uh
it's like a creative clay you bake i
don't think this is my thing necessarily
a fredrickson kiln multi-zone digital
controller solid state relays insulating
refractory i don't know what that means
but uh this is a nice looking kiln i can
tell you just from looking at this thing
this is a big-ass kiln 15 [ __ ]
thousand dollars i can tell you from the
owner of a kiln that's probably around
half the size they're really heavy and
you've got to kind of be careful with
them because the uh the the bricks that
the that make them up are fragile you
got to get a new power source you
probably need to get a gas line
installed if it's a gas one which i
think it is you know so plus
installation you're looking at a solid
17 000 bucks for this thing true flow
magic crystal blazer set of 12 for 233
bucks uh
i don't need these necessarily
the sink i actually had one of these
ones i've since got an actual sink
installed that's like one of the hardest
things this is going to be boring about
to say it's a disclaimer but the
cleaning up when you do pottery is one
of the most difficult things you want to
ruin your plumbing with all the clay and
this is a good alternative if you uh
cannot afford to get an actual sink
installed but 2 400 bucks like i would
call a plumber and see how much it gets
cost to get an actual sink with a clay
trap installed call your plumber call
your plumber i'm the grandson of a
plumber so that that's my go-to uh i'll
take the kiln frederickson kiln it'll go
nice in my uh portuguese uh eco farm or
whatever the [ __ ]
let's shop for ashraes all right
mid-century modern printed standing ash
uh yeah copper ashtray 16 grand
carl albock a [ __ ]
heavyweight
in the mid-century modern ashtray
game this is a beautiful ashtray i don't
know what kind of condition it's in it
says very good but the carpentry has
some signs of use so you know what if
you use your ashtrays that's about to
happen standing ash trees are great
because yeah if you don't if you don't
have a table or something to put it on
it itself does that for you and this is
a beautiful one and if you got 16 grand
uh burning a hole in your pocket then
this is a good ashtray for you and it
might remain uh
valuable you know again
carl albach ducey dice astray no i did
own a stucy dice t-shirt when i was
younger so i think there's something
nostalgic about it but i do not need
this ashtray here may's mosaic ashtray
800 uh i actually own a few air maze
ashtrays the thing about their maze is
they kept making ashtray they might even
still make them like they're not
necessarily
old or like rare they they pumped out a
lot of these things and they're lovely
but
uh i don't know if you bought this if
you feel like it was worth 800
necessarily oh we have one of the
largest private ashtray collections in
the world
when it comes to like vintage ashtrays
yeah we have hundreds of hundreds and
hundreds of them yeah ooh and the
houseplant ashtray designed by me the
very reasonable price of 95
deep notch
saucer matching vase for flowers it was
an ashtray that filled the need that i
just didn't have like i want an asteroid
i didn't have to clean all the time but
something that wouldn't get ash
everywhere and i could walk around with
it and something with a notch that was
like a perfect little rest and then i
started um doing ceramics and i started
making my own ashtrays and i started
making little saucers for them to go and
i started making little vases and i
would put them on side tables and stuff
like that and people really responded to
them and like them and
there's not a lot of people currently
making ashtrays and stuff like that me
and their maze maybe and it's nice to
see that uh you know people don't have
to ash in like a mug or like a tin can
anymore um which is what i was using a
lot of the time you know the uh air maze
one is lovely but i'm going with my own
ashtray for shameless self-promotional
purposes and it's only around 16 000
less than the carl albac and since i'm
buying a lot of taj mahals to fill my
ranch i mean i gotta buy my own ashtray
don't i i'd be a real [ __ ] not to
all right thanks for watching me pretend
to spend eleven million three hundred
seventy three thousand five hundred and
sixty six dollars all in all i made out
like a bandit so uh thanks for having me